[Música]
el periodo sido nombrado por siete años
consecutivos como el mejor destino
astronómico y eso ha hecho que muchos de
nosotros nos sintamos muy orgullosos en
nuestro país ya que es evidente tenemos
todos los recursos para tener una
economía de clase mundial y creo que no
lo podemos negar que ricos se comen en
perú
pero hagámonos una pregunta realmente
todos los peruanos pueden comer rico o
incluso a uno es una planta parecida
todos los peruanos realmente pueden
comer
y el que con el tema de la alimentación
en nuestro país se me parte el corazón
en dos por un lado me llenó de orgullo
por toda la riqueza económica que
tenemos pero por otro lado siento
muchísima impotencia al saber que hay
tantos peruanos que no tienen que comer
según las naciones unidas son más de 3
millones de peruanos que sufren de
inseguridad alimentaria que viven en la
incertidumbre de seo y tendrán algún
comer mucho a ellos niños que tal vez
desayuné pero por la tarde no coman nada
o peor aún se van a dormir sin haber
consumido un solo alimento durante todo
el día
no les parece una paradoja cruel que en
el mejor lugar para comer en el mundo
hayan tantas personas sometidas al
hambre que es lo que pasa este caso que
nos falta en alimentos y de hecho no
según las naciones unidas alrededor de
14 millones de toneladas de alimentos se
desechan al año en nuestro país eso
equivale aproximadamente al 30 por
ciento de todos los alimentos que se
producen
pero lo más alarmante de todo esto es
que muchos de estos alimentos están en
perfecto estado y por ende aptos para el
consumo y podrían estar siendo
consumidos justamente por la población
que padece hambre
y todo esto pasa porque tenemos un
problema en la gestión de los alimentos
se desechan toneladas de alimentos aptos
para el consumo
únicamente porque han perdido valor
comercial por ejemplo aquellos que están
cerca de su fecha de vencimiento o que
han sufrido un error en el envasado en
el etiquetado o por ejemplo esas frutas
y verduras que encontramos en los
supermercados y porque estéticamente no
nos convencen o tal vez están un poco
más duros hasta uno mismo no nos quiere
llevar
se imaginan entonces todo lo que se
podría hacer con esos alimentos bueno
todo esto podría salir limpiando al 70%
de la población que padece hambre
para mí es inevitable sentir indignación
en un país como el nuestro en donde
miles de personas mueran de hambre hayan
tantos alimentos de propiciándose y peor
aún en perfecto estado
esta caso que no conocemos las
consecuencias del hambre como por
ejemplo la anemia y la desnutrición
que no sólo limita la actividad física
del niño sino también su capacidad de
aprendizaje y por ende afecta así a la
educación de miles de niños en nuestro
país de hecho un niño que no se alimenta
adecuadamente los primeros dos años de
vida no logra desarrollar por completo
su cerebro
y esto pone en riesgo no sólo su
potencial sino también hasta su futuro
pero este no es un problema de un niño
no es un problema a nivel individual es
un problema colectivo que nos afecta
como país porque tendremos ciudadanos
que no podrán dar su 100% y eso está mal
y lo tenemos que arreglar pero quizás un
problema más grande que el problema en
sí mismo es la indiferencia que hay al
respecto a veces siento que es tan
normalizado tanto y que se habla tanto
del hambre que a sunny nos mueve y por
ende nos sentimos ajenos a poder
contribuir a aliviarlo
pero esto no solo pasa en el perú de
hecho en el mundo se desecha más en la
tercera parte de todos los alimentos que
se producen quitándole así la
oportunidad a millones de personas
alrededor del mundo de poder comer al
día son más de 12.000 personas que
podrían estar muriendo de hambre pero
claro se siguen desechando alimentos a
tota del consumo
en nuestro país justamente para aliviar
ambas problemáticas el estadillo de
alimentos y el hambre
nace el banco alimentos pero una ong que
lo que hace es justamente recuperar
todos aquellos alimentos que han perdido
valor comercial pero que están en
perfecto estado para poder donar lo
entre poblaciones vulnerables que no
tienen acceso a alimentación esto lo
hacemos de la mano muchísimas empresas
por ejemplo están las empresas de
consumo masivo que nos abren las puertas
los almacenes para ir nosotros y
recuperar todos aquellos alimentos que
están cerca de su fecha de nacimiento
también están los supermercados son a
decía entienden sus fármacos a nivel
nacional de donde de lunes a domingo
vamos y recuperamos todos alimentos que
no ha logrado vender por ejemplo los que
los quedan sufrieron un error en el
envasado también trabajamos de la mano
de prensa de los portadores se
imaginarán la cantidad de alimentos que
quedan en los campos únicamente porque
no cumplieron con estándares de calidad
estético para ser exportados como por
ejemplo tamaño
forma un color y finalmente gracias a la
colaboración de los comerciales del
mercado mayorista recuperamos todos los
días
toneladas de alimentos como frutas y
verduras alimentos frescos e
instructivos que ahora en los donan y
antes eran desechados
todo esto beneficia a miles de personas
pero también beneficia nuestro planeta y
en las empresas donantes a las empresas
porque ahora se ahorran todos los costos
asociados al desmedro sus productos y
además tributariamente porque recibe el
certificado de nación con los cuales
pueden deducir del impuesto a la renta y
a nuestro planeta porque evitamos que
todos esos alimentos no se conviertan en
basura y por ende ya no impacten
negativamente al medio ambiente
desde el 2014 hemos logrado recuperar
más de 15 mil toneladas de alimentos que
de otra manera hubieran sido desechados
gracias a esto hemos repartido a más de
50 millones de raciones entre 300.000
personas en nuestro país pero no solo en
línea hemos hecho su trabajo en 18
regiones de nuestro país
creo que definitivamente estos números
demuestran que sí es posible aliviar el
hambre y el desperdicio alimentos
lamentablemente el hambre es algo que se
hace en todo muchísimo durante esta
pandemia generando graves consecuencias
en todos los niveles pero también ha
demostrado las ganas y la capacidad de
muchos por querer contribuir con los que
menos tienen por ejemplo han habido
quienes nos han hecho donaciones
monetarias para que nosotros podamos
comprar y distribuir los alimentos en
las zonas más alejadas del perú también
han habido los que se han sumado a
nuestros programas de apadrinamiento
para niños y también lo que como siempre
se suman como voluntarios donando su
tiempo y conocimientos
gracias a todo esto hemos podido lograr
lo inimaginable
hemos logrado que miles de niños y miles
de personas puedan ser alimentados
pero esta responsabilidad no podemos
dejar solo a organizaciones sociales
definitivamente hacía momentos muy duros
durante la pandemia donde cientos de
personas no se han escrito todos los
días porque ya no tenían que comer madre
desesperadas por no tener que darle de
comer a sus hijos y creo que conociendo
historias como estas no los podemos
resignar a vivir con este problema
- si sabemos que podemos contribuir
aliviarlo
por ejemplo podemos colaborar con el
banco alimentos con jana pack wii con la
acción contra el hambre con el hogar la
bienaventuranza el padre omar y entre
otras organizaciones sociales que
trabajan justamente para aliviar el
hambre de miles de personas en nuestro
país
pero es nuestra responsabilidad y no
solo de las organizaciones sociales
todos debemos hacer algo todo de la
manera en que podamos y creo que si
todos tomamos conciencia y asumimos
nuestra responsabilidad y sumamos de
alguna manera desde la que podamos
podremos contribuir a que ojalá todos
los peruanos tengan un plato de comida
de esta manera si será verdad que
tenemos una gastronomía de clase mundial
no sólo por nuestros deliciosos platos
sino porque todos los peruanos tendrán
un plato de comida
gracias